Sidakhan's husband, I know you're going
to watch this, bro. I blame you, bro.
Yes, you are the kawama of the house.
You are the leader. You should not be
allowing your wife to be casually having
male clients talk to whatever is for
that matter. Okay, we know all this
stuff is a lie. Yeah, we're here. I'm
I'm doing this video to protect the
honor of your wife for the sake of
Allahh. Got nothing to gain from it at
all.
Allahh is my witness.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhana wa
tala. So make it count brothers and
sisters and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1, £10, £100,
£1,000 that's going to be something you
will never regret on your makyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds on your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
Asalamaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys are well in. So um why am
I talking about this video? You guys are
going to find out inshallah. Before I
start, I want to praise Allah subhanaa
tala the most merciful, the most just or
praise his glory and gratitude belong to
him. Sadia Khan, a lot of you guys know
her as a psychologist who talks about um
the mind of a female female psychology
etc. And I'll be honest with you um
obviously I don't agree with everything
she says but she speaks a lot of truth.
Same with Andrew Tate what I said
before. I disagree with lot of stuff he
says but there's a lot of truth he
speaks and whoever the truth comes from
you accept it even if it'san toy
so um based on that though guys right
now there is a massive slander going um
that's happening now like I said before
I'm here to speak about justice and what
the shar says and as Muslims we need to
be very wary what we're seeing because
things people just think they can just
do videos come out and just accuse
people and label people and this that
this is a slander yes okay and this
things happen and we know it a couple of
months ago accusations of um you know
many people you know alhamdulillah
subhanah coming out about this and that
and based on zero Sharia like no
evidence that meets the shar and they
themselves admit yeah it doesn't meet
the Sharia standards but we're still
going to talk about it you slandered
somebody and you're going to get that on
your sins yeah alhamdulillah people just
jump on the bandwagon people that
dislike others so we're going to watch
some videos and see what Myron said what
Andrew Tate said and there's this other
guy subhan and I have a message for
sister sad cuz I know she's going to be
watching this and it's not a message
from me per se. I can give it a as your
brother. But Allah subhanaa tala has a
message for you my sister. Okay. There's
a reason why you why you're going
through this inshallah and we will come
to that. Let's dissect it one by one.
Firstly, I want to go to what Myron and
Andrew Tate said. Yeah. Which makes me
sick. Let's watch that. Inshallah and
then we're going to come back. I'm going
to show you guys something. This is my
gains from Fresh and Fit. I don't really
care for Fresh and Fit, but this is uh
just for the sake of the argument. Sia
Khan is a fraud. She has been talking
uh on me for years after I refused
to platform her on Fresh and Fit because
of her entitled attitude when I was in
Dubai one or two years ago. Uh she was
just exposed for allegedly cheating with
an engaged man as a sidepiece,
undermining her credibility. Years ago,
I called her uh out claim I called out
her claims of being in a long-term
relationship and presenting herself as
high value woman despite the fact that I
knew for certain she was actually single
and purposely lying on every podcast she
went on early in her career. So she was
lying about being she's like actually I
am cuffed. I have a husband so I can
talk about this or I have a boyfriend
whatever the you was not cuffed.
He was out here sucking schlong. The
worst part men take her seriously
spending thousands on her consultations.
Let me be clear gentlemen uh female
dating coaches advising men are
generally ineffective. Why? Because
women cannot fully empathize with the
male experience. They don't live it or
truly understand it. women navigate
dating with uh inherent advantages,
making it nearly impossible for them to
uh to offer practical strategies to
boost your sexual market value or
effectively approach women as a man
because they have zero value. This is
all gay. I don't really care about this.
Uh never asked the fish how to fish. Ask
the fisherman.
And then Andrew Tate replies, "Shit,
I never knew this until now, but
apparently
since she wanna be in a relationship,
quote unquote, she's in a relationship."
She had an interview with Andrew Tate.
She sucked him off. Really? Are you in a
long-term relationship? and you gave so
you either you cheated or you lied about
being in a long-term committed
relationship and you have shitty blood
after the
>> okay you can see this person is a vile
disgusting person I don't know who the
hell he is I don't even know if he's a
Muslim is this guy a Muslim
his name is Fi if you're a Muslim shame
what a disgusting person you are man
you're you you've read a text bro it's
it's like somebody making a comment
about you f I don't know if you're a
Muslim or not yeah I'll be honest with
you acting behaving like a non-Muslim
subhan allah if somebody came and said
that he's gay and he had gay sex with
you and I come and say how how could you
do that? How are you reading a comment
and automatically believe in it? Well,
why these if you're a Muslim what kind
of a shameless man are you man? Andrew
Tate, yes, you're a dirt bag yourself.
Yes. Okay, we're all I don't give a
crap, bro. If you're somebody who lies
about Muslims, stabbing people, etc.,
which is all lies, okay, there's a big
question mark about you, Islam. There's
a big question mark about we can't prove
it to other but there's a big question
mark on you, bro. My wrong know if
you're a Muslim or not, I'll be honest
with you. You know, you can bring people
like Tommy Robinson said who insults
your prophet. Bro, if I came and
insulted your mom, Myron, I know you're
going to watch this, myron. Yeah. If I
come in and assaulted your mom, would
you have me on your show, bro? Yeah.
Would you have me on your show? But
someone that insults your prophet, you
bring him on your show like his happy
days and he has a right to Okay. If I
assaulted your mom. Yes. I know your mom
is if I'm saying he's a Muslim and I
would never do that. Alhamdulillah.
Yeah. If someone insulted your mom,
would you like if I invited him to the
show? Said, "Yeah, have a say." And
start, you know, shame on you, Myon. And
shame on you, Andrew Tate. You deem to
be a Muslim. Yeah. And you are here
casually accusing another Muslim woman
of doing oral sex, whatever it is for
them. And then I've got this fi guy who
a flipping hell he is. Yes. Trying to
act like a macho man, etc. Carrying on
the in which is a slander. Subhan Allah
is so casually coming out your mouth. Do
you know what the flipping you're
speaking about, bro? Do you even know
what's coming out your mouth? The
prophet wasallam mentioned in a hadith.
Okay. Mentioned in a hadith seven deadly
sins. Okay. The prophet peace be upon
him said explain the seven sins that are
doom a person to hell is is in that is
narrated by two alkari and Muslim in
which was narrated that the prophet
peace and blessings of Allah be upon him
said avoid the seven sins that doom a
person to hell he said what are they oh
me of Allah he said assassociating
others with Allah shik witchcraft
killing a soul from Allah who Allah has
forbidden us to kill except in cases
declared by Islamic law consuming
orphans wealth consuming ribba ribba
which is interest fleeing from the
battle for men and slandering a chasteed
woman. Okay. Subhan Allah. Not only that
Allah subhana wa ta sent in surah in
about a when she was slundered. Those
who accuse chase women of adultery and
fallen to produce fail to produce four
witnesses give them 80 lashes each and
do not accept their testimony from them
for indeed they are rebellious. And for
those who come to say Islam is a
misogynistic religion. It is clearly
stipulating anyone that and it's it's a
woman her chastity chastity. If this is
a man because it's more harmful for a
woman's chastity to be tarnished. And
now you might come and say, "Hold on a
second. You're talking about Sadi." Yes,
she is wrong for not wearing a hijab.
She's sinful. She's wrong for wearing
tight clothes, etc. going out there
casually. Um, and the way she's been
speaking, which we're going to react to
another video, where this guy tricked
her into an interview, backstabbed her.
Subhan Allah. Literally trick literally
laughing. And I have a message for you,
Sister Sadh. And I know you're going to
be watching this, okay? And subhan
Allah. And I have a message for your
husband as well. I have a message for
your husband as well. Cuz you claim in
this video that your husband is there.
We're going to see that for yourself.
Inshallah. And you just I want to read
this inshallah. Except those who repent
afterwards and men their ways, then
surely Allah has forgiven, most
merciful. Subhan Allah. And those who
accuse their wives of adultery, but have
no witnesses except for themselves. The
accuser must testify swearing four times
by Allah and that he's telling the
truth. It's called. Yes. Okay. And the
fifth off that Allah may Allah condemn
him if he is lying. Uh for for her to be
spared the punishment she must swear
four times again. And the fifth off is
that Allah's curse be upon him. Okay. So
you can see inah Allah talks about this
and subhan Allah Allah reminds the woman
who's being accused. Do not think that
this is bad for you but this is good for
you cuz it's talking about yakyama. So
let's go to this video where um subhan
Allah Sadi Khan was dragged in convinced
by this guy who we don't know who this
is by the flipping clown here. Okay. um
coming there and um tricking her into
this interview and then using it to
attack her. Let's watch it for ourel
>> together.
>> That's a quote, That's a quote.
She mentioned the fact that she had a
dad and two brothers and if they find
out, you know, cuz she's Pakistani,
they're going to kill her.
>> So, it's just that it's because of my
father. If it wasn't for my father and
he was Pakistani, strict all of his if
anything gets back to him or my
brothers, it's a like
>> it's a big problem.
>> There's no way I can't live. She she did
a lot of this like trying to garner
sympathy but you know your boy I don't
care
>> if you're caring people man
>> that's it.
>> Um so I know you got
>> okay one second. So firstly this is not
from Islam. So what she's talking about
her father if they find out that she's
saying that her life will be in danger
with all due respect this not from Islam
by the way this is not there is nothing
in Islam that says for example if your
daughter was committing adultery or your
wife etc. You cannot you cannot take the
matter in your own hands and kill them.
this not this is this is this is uh
cultural baggage that's ignorance that's
enough to do with Islam so she is
claiming that if this goes back to them
etc uh again it's it's it's enough to do
with Islam yes and um if if a family
fears god and they actually believe in
Islam uh they should not harm in any way
shape form from this it's not from Islam
I'll be this is not from Islam simple as
that what's actually from Islam is if
your daughter comes and says they
committed that you can be angry of
course who would want that but in no way
shape or form you are allowed
to punish her. In no way, shape or form
you're allowed to punish her. Let's
carry on.
>> Like as a Muslim woman who's got brown
skin, the moment you come up in their
world, just like Jetty, the moment we
come up and you're not looking like
them, they automatically assume that
you're you're not real. You'll see white
content creators, white coaches, the
Murphy Hussies or the other kind of
coaches in the world, nobody asks,
checks, cares what their background is.
They just assume that they're perfect.
But when you're of color or particularly
in my position, I felt like um a woman
and you know, as long if you don't
you're not super old, you're not white,
you simply can't be qualified. I
definitely hear what you saying earlier
in regards to maybe other um content
creators maybe those of a different
complexion not receiving the same kind
of scrutiny but from my knowledge I
think you're probably one of the only
content creators in the space who uh I
think is like considered a psychologist
at least at this degree.
>> Okay. So here sister sister Khan you
basically in a nutshell was saying that
oh you know you're admitting something
which is that basically you do not have
the credentials and that if it was a
white woman with a blonde hair nobody
would care about it and that um you know
just cuz you don't look like them. This
is a sign from Allah subhanaa tala wall.
What you're going through sister is a
sign from Allah subhanaa tala for you to
turn back to him. It might be that
you're too immersed in the dunya and
Allah says we send a calamity to divert
a bigger calamity. The bigger calamity
is hellfire. The bigger calamity is
being question. Is it worth it? Because
at the end of the day there is
disobedience of Allah like the way
you're dressing. You don't wear a hijab
and many other stuff etc. Subhan Allah.
Okay. So here you are basically this
Allah telling you you're talking about
being like them. Allah subhanaa tala is
saying the Christians and the Jews and
these people will never be happy with
you until you leave your religion. So
you look like them with all due respect
from the outside can we say you're a
Muslim woman? Nope. There is nothing
that says that you're a Muslim woman. I
would not if I saw you on the road I
would not know is a Muslim woman. I
could say potential Muslim. There's a
very good potential she's not a Muslim.
What identifies you? Tell me. Is it
hijab Allahh stipulated on you? Yes. But
the beauty industry. Yes. The beauty
industry, the peer pressure, the
opposition, all this kind of stuff have
made you to look the way you are look.
You're fully beautiful. Is this haram?
It is haram. And your husband can be
seen as a the youth. Can be. I'm very
careful with that. Can be because my
brother, why are you allowing your wife
with all due respect? In Islam, we
believe that the man is the leader of
the house. Okay? And if a woman decides
that she doesn't want to listen to you,
brother, I would not keep a woman as a
wife with all due respect. So, I'm
trying to be just and fair here. Number
one, there's all slanders against her.
And any Muslim that goes and carries on
this about her and all that kind of
stuff, it is haram. It's a major sin.
Major sin that Saddan is getting your
good deeds on your she's going to be
getting your good deeds. And if you got
got no good deeds left, you're going to
be carrying her sins that you accusing
her of. How are you letting that, bro?
I'm so sorry, man. I'm not here some
like a little puff of a man. Yes. Okay.
Muslim men of simps. You guys have
become simps. Yes. And let me tell you
something. Your wives will be never
attracted to you, bro. They'll be never
attracted to you. That's why a woman
like her in a like stated in that dun
perspective she needs a man a real man
I'm not saying with all due respect to a
husband I'm not trying to stand you
anything but if you cannot control that
element bro I'm so sorry with all your
respect bro what kind of a leader are
you bro what kind of a leader are you
man with all your respect it might be
that you are trying to I don't know but
let's carry on and it shows you look
even though you're trying to be like
them did you gain anything no they still
throw you under the bus they still look
anyone that disobys Allah subhanaa tala
at the pleasure of people The people
would be displeased with you. Look at my
sister. Look what's happening. Do you
think they care about you? Look,
everyone's turned against you. Even
though I believe you speak some truths
about the female psychology 100%. Yes.
Because even autate I dislike him for
the sake of Allah. But he speaks truth
as well. Yes. We know we can get the
truth froml.
Yes. So here you need to bear that in
mind. It's a lesson from Allah subhanaa
tala. Let's carry on.
>> Around and post places online. Fact
number three. She claims that a lot of
this stuff was doctorred in regards to
her being a side chick. The screenshots
of the text messages.
>> The screenshots completely fake.
>> What are you going to do about it? Ask
doctor text me. What I can tell you is
that I happen to have access to some
screenshots that are not public. And
when I showed her, she looked a little
distraught.
>> So these screenshots are not everywhere
from my understanding. Can you see it?
>> I don't know. I have no idea what's
going on there. And who is that from?
>> Okay. To our position as Muslims is that
this is a slander. This is a lie until
proven otherwise. Islam. We follow
Islam. We follow the Sharia. We're not
like absolute jahils who came out lying,
slandering a brother. Yes. He done this,
he done that. And he admitted himself,
"Yeah, it doesn't meet the Sharia
standards. Are you a kafir? If it
doesn't meet the Sharia standards, what
the stand?" No, but it doesn't meet the
Shar stands, but we still need Bro, what
are you talking about, bro? You jah.
Yes, just because you made your whole
your ex-wife. We know you guys who I'm
talking about. Bro, you made a slander
about someone and a woman who goes to
the enemies of Islam who ripped the
Quran up. Yes. And we're going to take
her testimony. He goes to the enemies of
Islam. Subhan Allah. And then you made
the slander and it doesn't meet the
Sharia thing. We will defend anybody.
It's not just about that brother. Even
it's a sister. Okay. These thing can
cost people's lives. Okay. Subhan Allah.
Let's carry on.
>> You look a little distraught. You look a
little And I said, "You have nothing to
be scared about. I appreciate your
acceptance skills and these text
messages are great.
>> You did not say that.
>> I sure did.
>> No. Fact number four. Uh despite
claiming to be a psychologist, um she
does go and harass people and flames
them in the most disgusting way. I've
been buttering rubber to get her
comfortable to do this interview. up
toys. It's unfair what people are doing
to you. I I' I've blocked some of the
people. They've come to me with false
allegations and I want to be able to
talk to you about them. The first time I
tried to do the interview, she bailed
last second, but then I came back
around. It's it's not fair how they're
treating you.
The way I set up this interview is first
I just get her to lay out her facts. I
didn't accuse her nothing. I didn't say
anything like a lot of people.
>> There you go. Looks look listen
carefully. Yeah. He lied. He deceived
you. He backstabbed you. Wall the effort
that you go in like you know putting
yourself out there disabing Allah with
your clothing not wearing the hijab the
way you're talking to certain people as
well I'm so sorry don't respect vulgar
etc etc Allah will humiliate you Allah
will humiliate you anything that you put
before Allah Allah will humiliate you
with that thing this is a sign from
Allah look how he backstabbed you Allah
showing you no one is loyal to you not
your husband not your mom not your
children none of them are loyal you
except Allah subhanaa tala this is a
lesson Allah teaches us over and over
and over again. Nobody in this dunya
cares about you. And if Allah is the
only one that is loyal to you and always
tells you to turn back to him and is
always there even if you sin a hundred
times, million times as long as you
repent to him, put Allah first because
this is a sign, my dear sister, Allah,
Allahhana is showing you that he's there
for you. And this goes to anybody that
is sinning. Everyone's going to backstab
you, bro. Everyone's going to betray
you, bro. Your own mother and your is
going to ask Allah to throw you into the
hellfire instead of her. That is a day
where Allah says nobody knows no one.
There's no kin. There's no mother father
that day is a different day. That's what
Allah says in
you are busy with the worldly affairs
competition looking beautiful looking
whatever whatever et fit in the
narratives prove yourself to the the the
disbelievers you know oh I'm like you
etc. and they rejected you and they will
condemn you and they'll throw you under
the bus and they will trick you like
this guy to get an interview out of you
and then expose you. Why? And Allah is
showing you my dear sister, it's not too
late to repent and the only one that's
there for you is Allahh. Fix your ways
inshallah. Let's carry on.
>> Side chick on this level. Gives them no
stress. I told you I'm such a side side
chick.
>> No way. No way.
>> What are you going to do about it? I'll
have to have that attitude and I can do
it today if I want to. I can do it on
your wedding day and your birthday. I've
been in a situation where he's been with
you in the social setting, he'll call me
after.
>> And then I ask her specifically about
the voice message where she talks about
sucking um very aggressively.
>> This again I said brother and sisters
before subhan Allah to us according to
the Sharia this is fake. This we see
this as fake. This is not true. This is
a lie. That has to be our thing.
Otherwise brothers and sisters we fall
into a major major sin to accuse chas
you come and say oh she dressed
inappropriately. It does not make her
unchased woman. Okay. Yes, she's sinful,
but it does not make her an unchased
woman. Okay, there is nothing to suggest
that she's unchased. Okay, so therefore,
we have to be very careful. If there's
Muslims out there casually spending,
you're literally falling into major sin
that will lead you to the fire. The
prophetam said, "Anyone that promises me
what's between their lips and what's
between their legs, I will promise Jenna
to them." When you go and lie, look, if
you go and sleep around, do Z, etc., you
will end up in hellfire. If you spread
rumors about someone who is not keeping,
you know, the the private parts in a
halal way, etc. doing haram, you will
end up in the hellfire. Subhan Allah.
Let's carry on.
>> Calling over and over and over and over
again.
>> Photoshop a bit better, Karen. We can
see the curves in the wall. Not everyone
is raised to be a slute. Shut up. My
content isn't for hoes. Get off my page.
Kind regards. I asked her, is this kind
of behavior becoming of a therapist?
>> I would just say that in general, um,
just because somebody's a surgeon
doesn't mean that outside of their work,
they have to cut people's bodies open.
My girl. My girl. I can tell you this
much. If a surgeon acts like you act,
insulting people and harassing people
online, the job might have some
questions for you.
>> Oh, yeah. You could definitely use your
license for that.
>> I agree. I do agree that it's not great
conduct. And I got a really bad temper
on me. So, and which is something I
definitely have learned my lesson not to
bother doing, but I just see as like if
you're not my client, why do you get my
service? My service is a therapist.
You're not paying for the service.
>> Right. But but but to my understanding
as psychologists, um there's still code
of conduct. It's even if you're off the
job, there's probably certain behaviors
that they would say is unbecoming of
people in that profession. And then
that's like based off of like the job
that you're trying to engage in. This
shouldn't be things that you would
engage in if someone is a psychologist
or they hold these skills and if they're
behaving in a certain way online. That
would be something that would cause
losing their license. You're not a bus
driver. You know,
>> I do. Overall, I completely agree.
There's no point me um defending it
because I completely agree. It's
something I've been told for years. But
I have this and this is 100% my nature.
You can ask my husband who's right here.
I can't because I've been bullied so
much my whole life.
>> Again, always a victim. And she said she
has an anger problem. What else? Like,
man, you're a therapist. You
>> have all the connects, all the contacts
to do something about that, my girl.
>> And I'll have you know, after this call
was done, she went right back to
on people non-stop. I wasn't
doing psychology 100% I I would be a
drug.
>> In a nutshell, guys, I want to say some
last words, okay?
I blame men, bro. I blame men. I blame
sister Khan, your husband. I blame your
husband because Allah said he's got a d
over you. Yes.
I blame you, bro. I blame I know you're
going to be watching this. Yes, sakan's
husband. I know you're going to watch
this, bro. I blame you, bro. Yes.
You are the kawama of the house. You are
the leader.
You should not be allowing your wife to
be casually having male clients talk to
me, whatever it is for that matter.
Okay, we know all this stuff is a lie.
Yeah, we're here. I'm I'm doing this
video to protect the honor of your wife
for the sake of Allah subhana got
nothing to gain from it at all.
Allah is my witness to dishonor my I
just want to and whoever knows me knows
me. Whoever gets accused, slandered wall
these things cost lives. went to France.
There was sister called Sister Aisha who
she who took her own life because of a
fake video going around. Yes. For those
who deem me to be misogynist. Yes. Bull
crap. I went all the way there to
document because there was a false rumor
about her. This tarnishes a woman's
honor. Okay.
How are you letting your wife do that?
Bro, do you not have a backbone? Do you
not have a backbone, bro? If you are a
real man, let me tell you something.
Yes. And I tell all men, forget Sadi
husband, sad's husband, all men, you
guys are flipping s. You are cowards.
You don't even have the audacity. You
don't have the guts to tell your wife,
you're not wearing that, bro. You are
not wearing that. I would not like, of
course, do it in a wisdom. Look, like
look, with all due respect, you have
your boundaries. A woman respects a man
with boundaries. A woman respects a man
with a backbone and he knows how to lead
his house. Not just with, oh, I'm the m.
No, no, no. mercy with Rahma. Yes. So
don't get it twisted about this Mr. Mro
man except this fake that you have.
Yeah. This bull crap red pill. Okay.
All I'm going to say is that my dear
sister take this as a lesson. Allahhana
is sending you a sign and my uh dear
brother please wall let me tell you
something okay you are going to respond
your Allah is going to question you
about her. So bear that in mind
inshallah. Till then the lies and
slanders of Andrew Tate the shameless
man Myron we don't even know what the
hell he's about and this other fad
whatever he's called subhan Allah shame
on you slandering a Muslim woman because
you heard stuff okay subhan Allah like I
said before should I believe in stuff
somebody comes and says yeah fi done
homosexual sex with somebody should I
believe it should come and say how could
you do it yes you don't like it yes
you're going to watch this video yeah I
don't know who you are so don't do the
same to other people we should fear
Allah subhana wa ta'ala that's it for me
brothers and sisters till next time
asalam alalaykum What to